we're thrilled to be joined by your uh
the uh the king of lefrak city in uh
in new york city of queens new york love
love
love watching him with charles and
ernie and shaq on the nba on tnt
and he is here as well as part of the
jet academy
at jetacademycamp.com where uh
so many kids are we need to get them
outside and outdoors if we can in the
pandemic and get them moving around and
what better way to do it than have uh
basically right now uh an online camp
for basketball fans to log in anywhere
in the world and that's how kenny smith
is rolling into the rich eyes and show
how are you kenny
i'm good brother how are you better for
talking to you better for talking to you
how's everything in your world
everything
i i i got to tell you kenny and i said
this to shaq when he joined me on monday
it's like
seeing old friends and in this day and
age where
everybody's zooming in and and not
really being able to be together we're
thrilled that we're able to be together
here in our studio socially distant
seeing you four
uh guys uh in atlanta doing your thing
has just been a treasure it really has
kenny
well i appreciate that it's uh
definitely been therapeutic
as well so which i didn't know so it's
been good to have everyone back and
uh you know you do miss some of the
normancies of life
uh with everything going on and uh yeah
i do agree uh and take that
into a great consideration as i hear it
okay
great excellent and who's the least
socially distant one
uh though that need you need to make
sure that everybody's cool
which which guy has been infringing on
your space is that charles cause he's
one right next to you no no you know
what but probably probably you have to
remind shaq
the most you know you have to remind him
well he's also trying to run he's trying
to beat you to your spot half the time
lead me to the board you know he almost
tried to wrestle
you know chuck one night he's the one
you have to remind the most
well the funny thing is i think he's
just so playful i think charles came on
went on dan's show before this one right
here on peacock and said that he's uh
going to get out of the predicting
business for a while
kenny i no i'm like i'll be
i'll be a billionaire i just just go
opposite of him i'm just hoping that he
continues it
i don't want him to stop i definitely
don't want him to stop because you do
all you have to do if you're if you're
anyone who is a betting person
just that opposite he is on a roll for
the opposite
he's certainly on that i mean ever since
but he did look
pretty smart after game one i guess when
the blazers took care of business
against the lakers is this the lakers
team
the lot one that we've seen the last
three three games that that uh
that we're expecting to see at least
take the conference
kenny well i think i think overall you
know this is a
a a a laker team i don't know the west
is so loaded
that to predict that one team or two
teams is uh
going to you know just run through it
after the bubble
i think is a different scenario if you
know prior to the bubble this is the
laker team we've seen
but you know we we've seen some teams
step up over the last
you know two and a half weeks that
traditionally we probably had thought
that could do that
so out of the rockets thunder or jazz
which is the team you think the lakers
least would want to see
next up i think they're fearful of
anyone because
they walk on the court and lebron james
and a.d goes
well we have an advantage right i don't
i don't i don't think that they ever
fare anyone so i think that
scoring the ball you know in the last
three games has been something that we
had not seen
their ability to kind of you know go
over a hundred easily um we had not seen
even in the bubble so if they could
continue that type of atmosphere
with their defensive tenacity then
you know that's when it i think takes
another level and that's when
uh otavius caldwell pope and danny green
and uh javale mcgee when they're able to
get those 10 to 15 points and
and dwight howard that's when they're at
their most dangerous because even if
a.d and lebron play great that's only 90
points
at best one gets 50 one gets 40. you
know
that that would only be 90 points that's
not gonna beat
most teams so they they're gonna need
key contributions from everyone as well
i'll give you the floor and luca i know
what you said uh but i'll give you to
the
to the show quadcast listeners and
viewers right now
the performance that luca came up with
uh in that overtime game to not the
series at two games apiece
um people are referring to magic then
you know the time where he played center
in place of the injured
kareem where where do you think that
stands and he stands
for you kenny i mean
what makes a greater great is not that
it's not a series or
or or a season it's a consistency over
several
uh that's what makes lebron who he is
it's like
over the years like he's done this
uh and so i mean as great as that that
that um
exhibition was of what he did you know
it's the consistency of doing that
night in and night out playoff time
after playoff time
and winning series that advances uh i
think that's what makes
you know the greats the great now
arguably you know we look at what i
always said when he came into the bubble
this is not 2020 luca this is the look
of
we would have been seeing next year the
mvp candidate so you talk about him
you talk about donovan mitchell you talk
about dame lillard
and you talk about you know even a guy
like uh
devin booker you know where they've all
taken that like oh i'm here for 21
20 for 2021 season this is how they're
probably going to look
next year because you know that long
layoff allowed them to kind of
retool and rethink yeah i mean you could
throw
jamal murray in that mix too which i
guess leads me to ask because we haven't
hit the clippers yet and we
we will who are we not talking about is
it the raptors
who just steamrolled uh the nets
um who are we not talking about to get
it get a shot here
to to take this wide open seemingly
tournament
you know i still think that um you know
the clipper series isn't over you know i
i wouldn't say it's over
uh if if uh you know they have a couple
of days or a day
and if porzingis is able to come back
you know that still could be an
interesting series
but the rockets you know with russ
westbrook you know
if he comes back you know and he's able
to play
then all of a sudden you're like wow
this could be
a mix that we you know we haven't seen i
think the one thing that we've seen over
the playoffs of james harden is
that he gets worn down as the series go
on because
the ball is in his hand so much in that
system but with russell westbrook he
doesn't
um you know and that's what i think
oklahoma city's
taking advantage of it's like he's got
the ball so much in his hand
we can contain some of these things that
happen now uh
so and utah you know
with donovan mitchell the way he's
playing right and the way he's shooting
the basketball
and the ability that he's playing at you
know
those teams both denver and utah with
jamal murray those
they they all the west is wild and it is
wide open
yeah the the rockets and the the thunder
are playing the tipping off five hours
from now and it's just in a couple hours
from now apparently according to woj
that russell westbrook's gonna give it a
try
um do you think it's imperative that he
play in this game five the way that
things are playing out right now
um the way that the rockets shot the
ball
uh at the end of game four and just died
by the three that they frequently live
by
kenny yes i think it's important for him
to play because
you know because even though as great as
uh
james is i think he does need that
okay i don't have to be the initiator
all the time maybe i could be the
finisher
um and you know kind of like lebron did
all of his career he you know dwayne
wade and
kyrie irving and all of those guys who
weren't
made it easy for him to not always be
the
initiator uh and
i don't think russ i don't i mean i
don't think james gets that
and um you know those guys are really
great players
but to be the initiator on every single
play
on every single possession would wear
anywhere
do you think the um celtics and the
raptors might not play
kenny that the conversations that
they're having over the shooting of
jacob blake
would uh actually they they'd
i think we all you know are in a um
a um
reactionary thought process of what's
going on like how
i know that you know for the first time
last night even watching doc rivers
speak
i was like man
i really the first time i felt that
being in the bubble the guy felt
helpless
like well i'm in the bubble and i can't
even
do anything i can't join a march i can't
do anything and at times if i'm not
playing i'm just sitting in my room
um and i think that that feeling is
starting to come out
um i don't know if i don't know the
right answer to that honestly
rich i i think the the correct answer is
whatever they do you have to support um
because some things are bigger you know
guys miss
games because of you know family or
or birth of their children
and if they feel that this is important
as a team to miss
because mentally their minds aren't
in that space to play basketball i think
we'd have to respect that because
they've also given us time
to play in a profession you know in that
bubble
that it's uncharacteristic of anything
that we've ever seen in our lifetime
yeah i mean jaylen brown who we know uh
appeared
um at many protests uh in the wake of
the shooting of george floyd
tweeting out essentially i wish i could
go do that like
he literally said those words kenny
right
well i didn't know that and and again
it's just
a helpless feeling if you're in a bubble
and think about it in disney
you know what i mean like the iron the
ironic
part of that is that you're in disney
and you're supposed to be
you know callous or
or not even thinking about what's going
on in the
in the world and because you haven't
been
part of the world you've been in this
three mile radius
for months and months and this is the
kind of the thought process that i could
understand
like i didn't understand and until last
night and i saw the past and i was like
doc doesn't have that release he doesn't
get to release that like i do
i can do things out i'm i'm mobile i'm
mobile i'm able to
you know go see friends and talk to my
family and go talk to my nephews and my
nieces and
i could you know i could i'm mobile
where he is
stuck in a bubble and he can't do that
so he doesn't have the release and we
saw it first time i think firsthand last
night
kenny the jet smith uh from nba on tnt
joining me here the two-time nba
champion on the rich eisen show
and uh you've seen what's going on in
the real world and you know kids are
cooped up man
and um and to get him out get him active
and get him
part of a basketball world
jetacademycamp.com
walk me through uh why you thought of
this and what you're doing with it right
now
kenny well the very rich with the
pandemic and the social distancing you
know all the things that my kids
normally do have get cancer then all the
things i do for kids have been cancer
right so i was like well how can i take
that
and i created the first streaming
service for for sports
uh and i did the academy we rolled out
basketball with kemba walker trae young
victor la depot
brianna stewart brittany grinder and
we're your personal and trained
trainers for for an hour hour and a half
a day um and you know i'm rolling out
uh a next session because we're going
back to school so we do every weekend
live you ask questions direct we have a
session where
how to get a scholarship once we do the
workout go through
us and then we have college coaches come
on and just talk about
how you get a scholarship most people
think you got to play on the travel team
to do that
well there's kids have to do that so we
have that session then i got one for you
that you should join
is it the one is it the one that says i
want a dunk kenny is it that's one
question
i'm gonna put three seconds on your 40
time man
i'll give it three seconds i'm gonna put
three seconds on it man i got the
that trainers show you how all of the
things that make you more explosive
to the rim to the basket so that's you
so you will be great at the combine the
next year uh you know what
i need i need to work on that burst
you're right
i need a little burst so that i can get
that
that's all it is that's all it is so we
got that one and the last one i also
love it
i have the trainers who trade to train
the clothes i got
uh like chris brinkley and tyler wrap
who you know they train the james harden
to kevin durant for the world
those guys that's what they do so i have
them on
in a session you know and it's a
membership just like a gym membership
you sign up
it's a gym membership and you get access
to all of these things
and all you have to do is go to
jetacademycamp.com
again jetacademycamp.com and you sign up
and your kids get access to this
anytime even if you miss the live
session it stays on demand
you can watch it you can do it you can
do it multiple times
if you say this is a session that i need
to really work on so again
jetacademycamp.com and all the kids can
do that yeah again
september 12th through the 13th again
because it's on on weekends it starts at
noon eastern nine pacific and
as you mentioned and all previous
sessions are available on demand
september 12th to the 13th i want to
dunk
i would like to dunk kenny i mean
seriously um
can you can you give me a little preview
a little little suggestion
about my desire to dunk
there there are for explosion
there are certain plyometric things
that you don't need any weights that
work i i will tell you that
i never lift the weight in my life
and i was in two dump times three dunk
contests in the nba
at six for three so it's all i never
lifted
when i before i go growing up i never
lift weights until i got to the nba okay
so being able to fly through the air is
not all about lifting weights
lifting weights is to put is to preserve
it preserves
what you have it doesn't always build
what you have
well i appreciate you not just
suggesting i lower the rim
um uh i appreciate that
that you actually gave me uh some
helpful advice uh when was the last time
you dunked kenny when was the last time
you attempted and you got up and you
ripped one through last time i dunked
was five years ago
when was that five years what'd you do
the first time i really attempted
i have a i have a i have now a turtle
that won't go away for a year
so i'm focused on that just so i could
grab so my goal now is not to dunk is to
grab the rim with two hands
that's my goal all right to go up and be
able to grab it with your hands hey uh
before i let you go the first time i've
spoken you in a long time did you learn
anything from the last dance
from your college teammate did anything
you pick up watching the last dance you
go okay i didn't know that about michael
anything at all um
i was just surprised how open he was
he typically had never been that open to
the
people outside of the sport and so
that surprised me but the intensity
the i loved it it was like the
it was like must-see tv because i just
love the fact
of how he was breaking down
what most players think it wasn't even
that he thinks that way and he's the
only one in the world and that's what
makes him great
most players rich think that way
everyone
just can't back it up so when you think
that way and you back it up
the confidence level just continues to
grow
and that's what i saw with michael was
like oh so every time he has success
and you have that kind of mentality you
just get more confidence and that's what
separates good great players from good
players
is confident i get it so if that's what
i learned
is that success brings after you have
confidence and you work on it
and if you have success it just
continues to read more confidence and
you get better and better and better
yeah i loved it too
i i my takeaway is you you never wanted
to be that guy
on the ipad that the director handed to
michael to inform him of what
previously said you didn't want to be on
that ipad
that's it no question he's like him you
that means you were going to get laughed
at
and or you were going to get exposed
one or the other you did not want to be
on that ipad hand it to michael jordan
uh thanks for the time kenny um you know
tell charles through the plexiglas i
said hi and same to ernie on either side
we had shaq on on monday it's been a
pleasure let's chat soon man love being
here brother
right right back at you fellow native
new yorker
kenny the jet smith check out the jet
academy at jetacademycamp.com
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here